[Music]
thank you
Randy I think I may have been sending
you some mixed messages
I think that when I talk to you
about making your own decisions you may
have taken that as a call to action
and maybe it was
and maybe that's my fault
certain decisions
certain decisions that are bad decisions
good decisions and and they put me in a
difficult position
they put me in a bind
because it forces me
to hurt you
really want to do is help you
you leave me don't you
because
so let's just forget about everything
that happened
well forget about everything in that
house and from now on the rest of today
is about you
I'm gonna help you
[Music]
like really help you
then I can't have you getting in my way
I need you to work with me not against
me
okay
[Music]
yeah
we're Square
my ass she's on
that stuff Chris was saying about you
not having a girlfriend is that true
yeah yeah it's true
okay
your version
yeah
yeah that's good
it is yeah definitely
look you start having sex there's a
chance that whoever you're is gonna get
pregnant
and some poor kid's gonna be stuck with
you as a father
that's not the person
too many guys start to
do or they end up with kids they don't
want
those kids grow up and they find out
they only exist because they had horny
teenage parents
crack they they join a cult or worse and
start having their own unprotected sex
yeah
I'm beginning to think that most of
today's problems are directive social
effect the teenagers can't stop
themselves from each
other so really
you're doing the world of favor
you ever had one
girlfriend
yeah yeah I had one a couple years ago
what was her name
Lisa Lisa like the Simpson
what happened
her cat died
what do you mean
and then
wait
sort of stopped dating after that
because you got that
yeah
well kind of what what are you what are
you saying to me
what are you trying to say like you're
saying she said I can't date you because
my cat died no I didn't what did she say
we never really talked about it but you
never like hey you remember that time
you broke up with me because of your cat
no not really
[Music]
Randy no where are we where are we going
now I need cigarettes
is unbelievable
let's go
you know I saw you eyeballing the gun
when that pig drove by
I need you to remember what we talked
about
I don't remember do you
because I'm not so sure
top that off I'm gonna go pay inside
foreign
[Music]